good morning
everyone it is now
10:02 and I am going to open the r
session for the Judiciary Committee
subcommittee R session
and I understand I have a quorum I mean
uh I'm
present representative tessman is here
and representative
Stapleton uh representative Perez was
not able to make it
today and representative McBeth and
representative lonza aren't here but
where I have a quorum I want to get
going first of all would representative
staple
please do the Pledge of Allegiance thank
you to the flag of the United States of
America to the repblic for it stands one
nation under God indivisible Li justice
for
all we are here today to have
subcommittee work on House Bill
396 relative to State recognition of
biological
sex now we're not going to debate here
today we're just going to listen to
testimony anyone from the public that
wants to speak is more than welcome to
speak and then the committee is going to
make a recommendation to the full
Judiciary Committee which will be held
next month our idea what we'd like to do
with the bill so if there anyone in the
public that would like to speak speak
please come
forward don't have a we don't have a but
you can certainly you can certainly um
listen to people and discuss things you
just can't take any official okay okay
yeah okay I apologize this is my this is
my first time doing this and I don't
have a quorum but we can listen to The
public's testimony we just can't take
any action so do you two want to go
forward with
this okay we're going to go forward with
this session please go ahead thank
you hello okay there it goes um hi there
um my name is Lind Jake house and I live
in do and I am a co-founder of 603
equality which will soon be an official
nonprofit group for lgbtq people in New
Hampshire and I also worked on managing
the campaign that um successfully I
brought transgender non-discrimination
projections to the state in 2018 and I
am a non-binary transgender person
myself um from 2017 to 2018 when I
managed the campaign that updated our
Statewide non-discrimination law to
include transgender people that only
happened with strong bipartisan support
passing the Republican controlled house
195 to
129 passing the Republican controlled
Senate 14 to 10 and signed by governor
snu oh I can only begin to scratch the
surface describing the relief and Joy on
the faces of transgender community
members and their loved ones was
absolutely overwhelming that day we only
won non-discrimination Protections in
employment housing and public spaces
through many educational events and
House parties where trans people shared
their own experiences of discrimination
and explained what it meant to be
transgender to Representatives who were
often learning about it for the first
time HB 396 sends a dangerous message
that biological sex is more important
than gender identity by asserting a need
to differentiate based on quote unquote
biological sex in athletics
incarceration and private spaces
time and time again attempts to ban
trans people from participating in
athletics have failed in the state
politicians need to stop playing
political volleyball with trans kids who
just want to play the sport that they
love it's no coincidence that 50
individual School Districts The New
Hampshire inter Scholastic Athletics
Association and our state legislature
several times over at this point have
all arrived at trans folks deserving
full inclusion under the
law according to the LGBT movement
advancement project transgender people
are frequently placed in incarceration
facilities that do not reflect their
gender identities which puts them at
higher risk for increased violence and
sexual harassment by staff and other
incarcerated individuals some prisons
and jails frequently Place incarcerated
transgender people in isolation or
segregation under the guise of safety
however segregating or isolating
incarcerated people for long periods of
time not only has serious mental health
consequences it also limits their
ability to access programs and services
available to the general prison
population segregation also further
stigmatizes transgender people
highlighting their status and increasing
hostility when we were working to pass
the non-discrimination Bill some people
raised concerns that transgender people
were a threat to privacy in spaces where
people reasonably expect privacy like
bathrooms and locker rooms in the nearly
6 years since the law was updated there
has been no increase in public safety
incidents in restrooms which is also
true for the other 23 States and more
than 300 cities with full and
comprehensive lgbtq non-discrimination
protections according to freedom for all
Americans transgender people use
restrooms and locker rooms the same way
and for the same reasons as anyone else
and equally value safety privacy and
modesty transgender people exist
everywhere and need to be able to use
the restroom just like anyone else
additionally some might argue that
transgender people can have incl access
to inclusion in these spaces after they
have had gender affirming medical
procedures our law states that all
transgender people have
non-discrimination protections and
employment housing and public spaces
regardless of medical status many trans
people are not able to afford or access
a therapist or gender affirming Medical
Care there are real barriers to
receiving Medical Care and changing
legal documents that we all experience
whether or not we are trans gender and
we all have the right to keep medical
information private between us and our
doctors finally this bill completely
erases interex people whose sex is
neither male nor female intersex is an
umbrella term used to describe a wide
range of natural variations that affect
genitals hormones chromosomes or other
reproductive organs sometimes those
characteristics are visible at Birth
sometimes they appear at puberty and
sometimes they are not physically
Apparent at all although interex can
take many forms about 1 in 1,500 to
2,000 people are born with ambiguous
genitalia and are not assigned either a
female or male sex often interex babies
undergo surgery that force them into a
male or female box which they may not
fit into as adults if we believe in the
autonomy of every individual to freely
make decisions regarding their own
bodies and lives we must recognize that
many people do not fit in the boxes they
are assigned at Birth I am happy um this
testimony I sent to the
committee um at the previous original
hearing and I'm happy to resend it to um
the group gathered here today by email
thank you thank you does anyone have any
questions representative
stapled thank you for taking my
question uh can you state your name once
again I missed that my name is Lind jow
l i n DS last name j a k o
WS thank you um you also stated a few
statistics there a moment ago relative
to how
many are born with um not fitting into
well into either roles of male and
female I missed the numbers could you
repeat those again sure it's uh one in
1,500 to 2,000
people and and where did that statistic
come from please um I don't have a
source on that um from what I'm reading
right now but I can get that to you by
email and would that be um how
dramatic um a
differential in this regard would that
be relative to an average of those one
to to 1500 or the one to
2,000 um I don't know how many interex
individuals currently reside in New
Hampshire but when we're making public
policy we should H keep in mind the wide
spectrum of human experiences and not
assume that people fit into only two
categories and the last question the 1
to 1500 or the 1 to 2,000 is that a New
Hampshire figure or Regional figure or a
United States figure or a worldwide
figure that's a national figure National
figure you say thank
you any other
questions thank you for your testimony
have a good day thank
you is there anyone else in the public
that would like to
speak
thank you so much for your time
representative uh my name is Courtney
Reid and I serve as policy Advocate with
the American civil liberties Union of
New Hampshire and I just wanted to Echo
a lot of the uh statements of concern
about this bill that uh my colleague
Lind Jake house had expressed um I left
a handout for folks uh so I'm just going
to largely touch on some of the main
points um for your uh reference there uh
foremost uh the ACLU is concerned that
this bill would function to undermine uh
existing protections for granite Staters
um mostly the uh
nondiscrimination act that uh Lind had
mentioned earlier that was passed in
2018 um which had banned discrimination
based on gender identity uh in areas of
employment public accommodation and
housing uh but beyond um New Hampshire's
own laws to protect gender identity um
we've also seen uh Supreme Court rulings
at the federal level BOS V cleton County
uh which serve to protect discrimination
against gender identity in employment uh
specifically but uh a lot of federal
agencies have come to interpret this
ruling to also affect other areas such
such as um in schools uh affecting Title
9 um what this bill would do would send
a harmful message for folks whose gender
identity is not the same as their natal
sex whether that
be creating some sort of invasive or uh
surveillance procedure to ensure that
folks fit neatly into one box to perhaps
use a restroom facility or a locker room
or perhaps even affecting uh prison
settings um which other Advocates who
I've spoken with uh have also expressed
concern about the implications that uh
should local jails and prisons decide to
utilize this law they could also be
undermining priia the prison rape
elimination act uh in that uh prisons
and jails may not be
uh providing accommodations for uh
transgender and non-binary folks so not
only um could this affect their
placement but also uh potentially the
need to shower safely and separately
from other inmates or the need for um
menstruation products and
whatnot um and I just wanted to Echo
that uh the bill is hostile and serves
to just further alienate transgender
individuals and that by excluding trans
and gender nonconforming individuals in
sports or in other areas of life were
sending a message that they're not
worthy of the same kinds of
opportunities as classmates or
colleagues and that the folks who this
bill would be affecting need support an
affirmation and not to be a political
Target um and like I said uh I'm open to
taking questions but I I think a lot of
the information I'm hoping to get across
is in this handout thanks does anyone
have any
questions representative Stapleton thank
you for taking my
question your handout here and uh
testimony may I ask if that was based on
the original
bill or um
considering one or both of the two
amendments that followed in in sessions
uh committee
sessions
um I would have to get back to you on
that I believe this is about the
original bill but
um because there there were two um
amendments a um Lyn
Amendment and um which was number
61h of uh May
7th and then there was a following perz
Amendment
20230 441
H well that's also dated uh 507 of uh
2023 M and substantial changes
amendments were made to the original
Bill focused on protecting
constitutional rights and uh enabling U
much of what you site in there uh to be
Express and protected but with the
ability to recognize biological sex um
in facilities where appropriate and
needed now you need to take a look at
those two amendments because I think
you're going to find uh some vast
Improvement um against what your
original testimony is that's just my
opinion but um I'm directing you to look
at at those new
amendments thank yeah uh I appreciate
that I will take a look at it and uh get
back to you thank
you any other
questions thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else that
would like to
speak
good morning Madam chairwoman and
members of this uh
subcommittee uh my name is Jim kofalt I
am the I represent Hillsboro County
District 32 uh Wilton Temple and new
ipswitch and I am the prime sponsor of
houseville
396 um I I guess I wanted to take a few
moments today
to reiterate the the reason that this
bill is necessary this bill is necessary
because we need
Clarity to me the law is
clear however to a number of others it
is not that includes for example the um
the US District
Courts the 11th circuit court has upheld
a Florida law
that um allows school districts to um to
segregate bathrooms based on biological
sex the fourth Circuit Court um ruled
that a similar law in Virginia was a
violation of anti-discrimination
law even our own Department of Justice
here in the state of New Hampshire seems
to have an ambivalent view on this topic
they voiced their opposition to House
Bill 396 on the basis that it uh did not
conform to our state's
anti-discrimination laws um and yet they
also exercise um discretion in
segregation of prisoners in um
in um New Hampshire prisons um so they
you know by their own testimony address
cases on a case-by Case
basis um and so you know I I I guess I
would say that that there is a lack of
clarity in this battle is really being
played out in a lot of school districts
around the state um that's costing a lot
of money it's costing a lot of time uh
but the bigger concern of course is that
it is
um you know I I believe violating the
the rights of um young students many who
are going through um changes in their
lives um who want to be able to um use
the bathroom or the locker
room um in uh
you know in in privacy and um and and
modesty
so this is actually playing out in a
number of school districts around the
state one of those is uh happens to be a
school district that uh my my house
district includes and that is the mic
School District so new whip switch being
the largest town in that school district
um is in my district and um there you
know we heard testimony at the
introduction of the bill from a mother
in Milford who's who herself is a victim
of sexual violence and you know
tearfully told us that she is simply
trying to protect her daughter and give
her daughter an opportunity to um you
know to to use the locker room or the
restroom um with a feeling of privacy
and
security
um the same situation is playing out now
in the scenic School District it's
playing out in other school school
districts and what has happened there is
that the
um the attorneys who the the school
district's Law Firm has come and said
well you know our interpretation of the
law is that you have to allow this
biological male who is identifying as as
a female to use the girls locker room
and the girls
restroom um there are other legal
experts and as I said the 11th Circuit
Court affirms this opinion
who say that it is not
discriminatory um I would I would also
highlight the fact I think one of the
previous um people who spoke
um compared this to discrimination or
brought up the topic of discrimination
in employment this bill has nothing to
do with discrimination in employment um
discrimination in employment is is
entirely
illegal uh it would remain illegal if
this bill were to move forward and pass
um
so you know I I think the the you know
there also is a characterization of this
bill as being
hostile um you know I take exception to
that I I really think that the um the
fundamental question is can we can we
all get along and um you know I I think
that that calls for a a mutual respect
this bill is not intended to be
disrespectful nor have I ever
um have I ever expressed an erir of
hostility in in talking about why this
bill is
necessary um I I think this is common
sense a couple of uh years ago we were
we were you know everybody was using
that the me too hashtag and talking
about how important it is to protect
women um and and I do not believe for a
moment that every transgender person is
is uh in fact I think the vast majority
of transgender people um are they just
want
to get along and fit in and and be
respected and I appreciate
that what I you know what I'm concerned
about is these cases in which the lack
of clarity in the law has provided a
basis for um what I would call undue
license where we have people going
into uh a girl's bathroom or locker room
taunting and making fun of young girls
who are going through puberty and who
are embarrassed about their bodies at
that point in life to begin with um and
this simply says let's acknowledge that
there is such a thing as biological
sex and
that separation of bathrooms and locker
rooms and prisons and athletic
competitions um based on biological sex
is reasonable and allowable it does not
dictate that it does not tell school
districts or the
doj what they have to do it simply
provides some clarity and says that in
if you do distinguish based on
biological
sexs that is
not that is not um discrimination that
that would be um violating our
anti-discrimination
laws thank you thank you representative
kofalt does anyone have any
questions representative
Stapleton thank you madam chair thank
you for taking my
question
risk there's actuality and then there's
risk
um is am I correct to assume that what
you're pointing
at is the risk that is opened up and
made present by um the open use of the
public facilities especially in
school and that risk is a concern to
many
people and it's a valid concern for
possible danger even as few of an
incident that might be occurring because
of open
facilities I see in the in the public
venue many in businesses are um opening
their toilet facilities to um both
gender
use and some
um you don't have many facilities so um
that makes sense but it seems to be
pretty ubiquitous that that's happening
all around and I thought occurred to me
the question occurs to me is why
couldn't schools keep their biological
separation for safety
modesty security
propriety and provide um another
facility whether it be from the teachers
lounge or whatever for those who uh
whose gender their identity doesn't fit
them well for either or the male or
female um Can can you give me
some feedback on on those ideas and and
that question about
risk thank you for the for the question
so on the as to the first question I
mean we heard in testimony a few minutes
ago about the need for um transgender
people in in a prison setting for
example to be able to shower or use the
bathroom in
safety um and I do not for moment deny
that there are incidents of violence
against transgender
people um having said that there are
also incidents of sexual assault when
you put biological males and females
together es especially um you know young
people uh teenagers and so forth so I I
do believe that there that is present I
would say even if that were not present
I think that there is an issue of of
modesty and privacy that we ought to
acknowledge as to the other question um
I would I I think we need to be careful
about
um if if
you if you designate certain bathrooms
as being or transgender people that is a
kind of that that's that kind of fits
the separate but equal which is not
which which is not an
acceptable approach to dealing with with
people of different groups the
acceptable approach would be to say we
have a a bathroom for biological males
whatever your gender identity is if you
are a biological male you may use that
restroom we have a separate restroom for
biological females whatever your gender
identity is you can use that one and we
have single use restrooms that any and
this is the key part that anyone may
use um whether you are a transgender not
transgender doesn't matter anyone may
use but that essentially tells everybody
you you you have the same you're all in
the same situation you're to use the
restroom that corresponds to your
biological sex or if you prefer whoever
you are if you prefer you can use one of
the single use
restrooms thank you may I have a
followup
y um with prior
testimony I um made reference to two
amendments that followed on top of your
original Bill uh the Lyn
Amendment
um and then the Perez Amendment had you
had an opportunity to review either th
of those and can you give some comment
on how that may support your bill or
detract from
it thank you for the question so I have
reviewed them both I don't I'm I'm
trying to recall the Perez Amendment the
the Lyn amendment I believe was focused
on the athletic competition
portion um and it made some changes to
the language surrounding athletic um
athletic
competitions um and I I think that was
an entirely acceptable change um I I
remember that I I I don't recall the the
details of the Perez
Amendment thank you yeah the Perez
Amendment um Incorporated uh much of the
Lynn Amendment and then made some slight
word additions to it
um and you know
um I'm not sure what that was but the
change portion of the um both the Lynn
and the Perez amendments which are are
pretty much
identical in uh they they um add in
Roman
2 the general court also finds that that
notwithstanding New Hampshire's
fundamental commitment to treat all
persons without
discrimination and with equal dignity
and
respect which commitment the legislature
fully accepts and strongly
endorses there are certain limited
circumstances in which classification of
persons based on biological sex is
proper because such classification
serves the compelling State interest of
protecting the priv privacy rights and
physical safety of such persons and
others the legislature finds that
permitting classification of persons
based upon biological sex serves this
compelling State interest in the three
circumstances described in RSA
354 d a colon
25A that is the substantial change of uh
in those
amendments do you find
that helpful objectionable um or without
effect thank you I I I certainly think
it it underscores the intent that is
already there in the bill so I think
it's helpful um the language I was
recalling from the from the linnn
amendment had to do with athletic
competitions pertaining to speed and
strength if my memory serves me
correctly um so I believe that that was
potentially another change in that one I
do want to comment though on um the the
statement in what you just read that a
distinction based on biological sex is
proper in speaking to some members of
the transgender Community what I heard
about this bill is you know you will
never get anybody in the transgender
Community to support any bill that uses
the phrase biological
sex um because there is a um and I am
paraphrasing here um but there there
there is a um a desire not to
acknowledge that biological sex is is a
valid basis
for classification at all and um that I
think I mean we we heard again we heard
testimony a few minutes ago saying well
this bill erases intersex people um I
think generally speaking when we make
law we try to um be specific enough but
we we also try not to
um to make law based around um outliers
and exceptions and um
the you know the the concern that I have
here is actually
that there is a move of foot to to erase
the the the reality that there are men
and women boys and girls in the world
world and that much of our society is
organized along those lines I think that
we can be open to people stepping into
different roles we can be respectful of
people
who have a different gender identity
than that which with they were with
which they were
born but the fundamental reality is you
know still that people are born one way
or another way and on occasion you know
there there is some ambiguity with in
the case of intersex people but you know
that that I think the the the statement
that a distinction the distinction based
on biological prep uh sex is a proper
distinction is fundamentally what this
bill is
about thank you so if I if I get that
respect for
individuals regardless of the many
qualifiers
sex gender religion ethnicity so forth
this all fits within that realm of um of
respect um of people because we we
talked
about the athletic aspect
um I'm going to go through there there
is a new section in that just to get a a
basis for uh understanding about what
we've talked about very short uh it's on
page two of the
um of the Perez
Amendment it's TI titled new section law
against discrimination
classific semic calling classification
of persons based upon biological sex
amending RSA
354a by adding after section 25 the
following new
section 354a colon 25A classification of
persons based upon biological sex not
withstanding RSA 354 d a colon 2 Roman
14- e or any other provision of this
chapter or any other law or
regulation it shall not constitute
unlawful
discrimination based on sexual or gender
identity for any person or organization
public or private to classify based on
biological sex with respect to the
following matters Roman 1 in the
construction maintenance operation and
use of laboratory facilities or locker
rooms designed for usage by multiple
persons at the same time even if such
facilities have individual urinal stalls
or similar
apparatus Roman two in athletic or
sporting events or competitions in a
sport or similar activity in which
physical strength speed or endurance is
generally recognized to give an
advantage to biological males and Roman
three in the operation maintenance and
use of facilities designed for usage as
prisons houses of Correction juvenile
detention or commitment centers mental
health hospitals or treatment centers
and like facilities to which persons may
be committed
involuntarily it closes effective date
this act shall take effect 60 days after
its passage and that's the end of the uh
Amendment with the new
section um it cited your reference to
the athletic of course in Roman 2 do you
have any further um thoughts uh hearing
that um reflecting on that relative to
the new section
the the only the only thing I would
point out is that that
um extends the bill to private
organizations the original bill is aimed
specifically at the state and
subdivisions of the state so it affects
prisons and public schools
essentially um so it expands the scope
um I would leave it to
legal opinions and I'm sure we would
hear legal opinions on both sides of the
issue as to whether or not um that makes
it you know whe whether or not that that
is likely to uh to hold up in the courts
and as I've stated earlier even the sort
of the view the view of of bathroom
policies in schools relative to Title 9
has been treated differently by
different us circuit courts um and the
Supreme Court has refused to hear on the
uh fourth circuit they they've refused
to hear that case so the fourth circuit
decision as as of now
stands for for Virginia and the 11th
circuit decision stands for
Florida a different 180 degrees
different it's a difficult subject and I
thank you for um your testimony and
reflection on my questions and on the
just uh on the amendment just read we
try to do uh the best we can in respect
for all people but we do want to keep
the safety privacy
modesty uh and risk element down for a
great amount of of people in our
society uh coordinating with uh our our
traditions and and reality of a
biological reality thank you thank you
is there any other
questions representative
McBeth excuse me L I'm sorry I apologize
it's okay um thank you for taking my
well it's kind of like a statement did
you know that when children are born um
that um the parents can decide to um not
put male or female um as a um when board
now on the birth certificate they can
actually choose to not um choose male or
female on the um actual uh birth
certificate in New Hampshire that's the
current okay I I actually wasn't I was I
was aware of the um amending uh birth
records and the laws surrounding that I
was not aware that you could that
parents could choose to not assign a sex
of birth thank
you I only have have one question were
the
Amendments has the original intent of
your bill been changed or expanded so
much that it'll never get
through um I don't believe that it e
either of those
amendments um based on what I recall and
what I've heard today I don't believe
that either of those amendments
fundamentally changes the intent of the
bill okay thank you thank you thank you
for your testimony representative
CA is there anyone else in the public
that would like to
testify please come
forward did okay somebody did you have
your hand
up
okay all right seeing there are nobody
else that wants to
testify I would like each one of us to
give their opinion
because I'm not sure if we need to make
a decision today what I would like to do
and you can tell me whether you agree
with me or
not what I would like to do is
recommend to the full Judiciary
Committee in
November each one of our opinions CU I
think you know there's some many things
our opinions are different and it
doesn't have to be anything long I just
think just a short of what our
recommendation is in our opinion would
do it uh would you please let me know
how you feel about
this um I would agree with that um that
I'd like to Al let say look things over
a little bit more carefully and then um
come back um maybe with a summation um
to prevent present and maybe to the um
Judiciary Committee and then for us all
to decide on there do you feel we should
have another work session or we just may
give our opinion at the full
hearing when we do the executive session
um I'd like to see possibly another
meeting okay I'll see if we can work one
in because I think it's what in nove the
first part of November that we have our
executive sessions and I'll see what we
can do okay representative testman what
is your
opinion would you speak into
the I'm in favor of the
bill the amendments are okay but basic
bill is okay also do you think we should
have another work
session
no representative
Stapleton I too am in favor of the bill
as amended with uh the per the Lynn and
Perez amendments but namely the Perez
amendments because that followed the
Lynn
Amendment and as we heard in testimony
it does not detract from challenge the
original intent of of the original
author's
Bill uh I think we've considered this
long enough and I am not in favor of uh
any further work sessions uh I'm
I'm going to make a motion that um we
recommend the passage of uh uh recommend
that the uh committee um passed this
bill uh based on the uh Perez Amendment
thank you is anybody second that
motion okay all in favor pre please
raise your hand and they're in favor of
the motion to recommend to the committee
that we pass this bill all is oh all is
opposed may I ask um how many um other
people in our subcommittee are here or
are not here today okay Chris
representative Perez she's not here she
had to go she went to Canada and
representative MC Beth is not
here so we have a vote of 3 to one to
recommend that this bill with the
Amendments pass to the full committee
Judiciary Committee be passed and so
there's nothing else if somebody wants
to make a motion that we close this
meeting please do
so anybody second that question before
your second excuse me
um as you point out that u w with our
recommendation to for passage of the
bill it does not preclude further
amendment to be presented to the full
committee that they could consider
so um I think moving this forward uh is
expedient for process and uh getting the
bill through committee and then getting
it to the floor I that's why I voted um
to support the bill with the Perez
amendments so that we did not have
further delay as we end up this year and
go into the next year of our
term uh thank you I agree with that my
thing on House Bill 396
is to get it to the full house because
as far as I'm concerned that's where it
belongs let the Full House debate it
it's 400 people and then let them vote
on it and you know what either be yes or
no that is
396 yes right yeah okay so your motion
and please excuse me your motion was
just on the original bill it wasn't on
the amendments no my motion uh includes
the uh Amendment um the Perez Amendment
which was yeah do you have would you
give me the number on that
right the per the Perez representative
Perez Amendment um of February 8
2023 uh two number
2023 d0
H okay thank you okay is there anything
more if there isn't I'm calling the
meeting to a
close